we need to have plans for our future
divide the donkey and Japan not to talk
about the plants is that right
no because I need to talk about to
always talk about the plants every day
this is the day because I will paint
I'll talk about Supply Our advice is
talk about the plan I will go out this
psychological talk about the plan let's
stand up for today which are a bit about
the plus and talk about everything today
okay but when I talk about the future
and needing security you always kind of
say well we'll talk about it later
I don't want to push you at all but I
feel I need to make plans okay
that's okay a little bit like can we
look at apartments online tonight maybe
we can
me and Osama have these wonderful deep
conversations via texting and now it's
like do I have to get out my phone and
text him to have these honest Heart to
Heart conversations now that I'm here
large in person I'm getting nothing man
I'm getting nothing
you said that I would come here and you
would love me and take care of me and
you would prove it and now it's like you
just kind of like oh shut up Debbie I
don't want to talk to the hand right you
think I'm not patient yep because you
want to do everything right here right
now I didn't want you to do it right now
I just wanted you to sketch an outline
of our future and we just stopped and I
mean I would not do everything in one
day I feel crazy
will not do everything in one day
you are sick
you have the amount of seconds or
something
what
what to say times what's going on with
this lady
I don't get it man so you think I'm
mentally ill
you're acting real cold-blooded right
now and this is making me angry I'm not
angry in my nature that's making me feel
house inside and you don't think I'm
feeling hurt right now
you don't think I hear my kids saying
mom I Told You So this guy can't take
care of you this guy is not going to be
straight and honest with you you don't
think I can hear them saying that Mom be
careful
I want to talk about serious things and
you act like a oh you're crazy you're
mentally ill
so we joke about the plants
our plan is you will come here and bring
me to the USA and I will go to work
there and we start our left there we can
guarantee the future here this is our
plan and I went from this day never
change it if you don't accept this we
can't stop all this
[Music]